in today's morning rounds a win for
weekend workouts a new study finds
people who squeeze all their recommended
exercise and weekends see major health
benefits so-called weekend warriors have
a thirty percent lower death rate
compared to people who are not active
dr. Jordan metzel is a sports medicine
specialist at New York's Hospital for
Special Surgery good morning good
morning guys how are you good so what
did this find is this research that we
could be inactive during the week I can
make up for it on the weekends people
cheering everything exactly listen I'm a
big fan of exercising every single day
so I don't want to take this study too
far I think with this showed was it if
you do nothing that's not good for you
if you do nothing during the week and
you do a lot on the weekend that's
better than doing nothing I'm still a
big believer that doing a little bit
every day is probably the best thing to
do yeah but the goal was 150 minutes a
week right that's right the american
college of sports medicine in the
american number of the medical societies
talk about 150 minutes per week as the
really the goal you want to get the
medicinal value of exercise it's two and
a half hours two and a half hours a week
what about high intense workouts them
that are for 10 to 15 minutes that's
right do the job you bet you they do
some I'm really interested in the
science of intensity and high-intensity
workouts and what I found is that kind
of compressing network out at 10 15 20
minutes first thing in the morning is
tremendously helpful you can really
maximize your benefits so it's prob
about a two to one conversion so if
you're doing 15 minutes of
high-intensity it's about 20 probably 30
35 40 minutes equivalent of a moderate
exercise period I've heard you say that
it's the most effective drug in the
world you just mentioned to Charlie
about medicinal what do you mean exactly
by that yeah Gail so actually we're
doing an interesting program now at
Cornell med school we're doing a thing
it's called prescribing the medicine of
exercise it's a second-year medical
school curriculum seminar I love this so
much and the concept is that everyone
knows like exercise is good for you and
I'm here like all right all right ladies
over way be here they don't know that
already Jordan I don't blend you but I
what he does it people are more likely
to take a pill then x rays yeah but
would you know that's why you say the
issue is the medicinal meaning that if
you took the medicine of exercise and
you looked at the efficacy of this
across the entire spectrum of the human
body starting with the brain kind of
memory anxiety it's the only drug that's
effective against dementia it's been
proven to prevent 13 types of cancer
cholesterol diabetes
it's really the most effective drug we
have no side effects it's free and it
works for every single person that takes
it and so teaching people not to think
about exercise as it's good for me but
there's actually a very strong medicinal
component to it is really important and
then thinking about teaching doctors of
the future how to prescribe it is I
think Laurie exercise along your loop
yeah yeah that hadn't taken a pill and
not only how long you live but how well
you've altar boy but I did think it I
think it was helpful to know that if for
some reason you're really busy during
the week if you're that you can make up
for it on the weekend it's not ideal but
it you can make up for it that's good
something is better than nothing thank
you dr. Jordan metzel